senior metropolitan police chief has
defended the actions of his Force saying
he was not pressured by the government
into cracking down on protesters during
the coronation temporary assistant
commissioner Matt twist has been
answering questions from a committee of
MPS following criticism of the way
officers handled demonstrators in light
of the government's new public order act
that became law in the week of the
king's crowning
I felt under no pressure politically I
felt pressure to deliver a safe and
secure operation but that was because of
the fact it was a once in a lifetime
event for so many people and there would
be hundreds of thousands of people in
London to celebrate it the stakes were
enormously high so I absolutely felt
pressure to deliver a safe and secure
operation but that wasn't political
pressure that was the pressure to do a
good job
ironically ironically though the hearing
about the best way to police
demonstrations had to be briefly
suspended when it was interrupted by a
just stop oil protester
you usually use a combination lock to
stop and
we're here today
okay it did go back to the proceedings
but they were interrupted for that just
stop oil protester let's bring in our
crime correspondent Martin brunt he's
been watching the whole thing it was
extraordinary wasn't it the level of
detail that we heard in that um hearing
was fascinating it um it was indeed and
uh fascinating detail from both sides
um first the Metropolitan Police
assistant commissioner Matt twist we've
just heard a bit from but he went into
great detail about how the intelligence
picture the threat of disruption built
up overnight I mean we haven't been
privy to what um what the police were
getting but it was enough he said for
for senior officers to have to brief the
Home Secretary in the mayor of London
late on the Friday night but he talked
about the threat of people throwing
paint they arrested some people carrying
white paint but the the fear was that
they were going to spray monuments there
was Intelligence he said that people
were going to jump onto the procession
route and interrupt him and there were
other bits of intelligence that
suggested people wanted to set off loud
noises and scare the horses which could
have caused he said very serious injury
so that was from the police from the
protesters and particularly those
subjected to the first use of those new
very new powers on the day particularly
those Republic
anti-monarchists they were held for 16
hours on suspicion of planning to lock
themselves to objects or to each other
and cause a major disruption we heard
from Graham Smith one of those arrested
the chief executive of Republic who said
that the weeks and months of liaising
with the Metropolitan Police and laying
out their plans and saying there was no
intention to cause any disruption none
of that counted for anything on the day
this is what he said said
immediately we were surrounded by large
numbers of tactical support group
officers who were not in remotely
friendly or helpful mindset they
immediately told us to stop what we were
doing I attempted to phone the liaison
officer and he told me that he was
therefore detaining me and did not allow
me to do that I attempted again and he
seized my wrist and removed my phone
from my hand and again told me I could
not do that I told him that we had had
these meetings with a superintendent and
silver Commander I he said what was the
name of that person I told him he
clearly recognized that name and he said
that did not matter
the um the senior police officer Matt
twist said he still felt that those
arrests were lawful um the force hasn't
apologized for them but it said it
regretted that those that were held for
so many hours were prevented from taking
part
um in the protest
um we heard two from a volunteer one of
those other group of individuals who
were arrested on the Friday night
um Susie Melvin was a volunteer working
for Westminster Council she and her
colleagues were looking after vulnerable
women people making sure they got home
safely in the early hours of Saturday
morning they were suddenly swooped on
she said their bags were searched for no
apparent reason and they've been in the
process of handing out rape alarms but
the police appeared to interpret that as
you know preparing for some kind of
protest as I said earlier about scaring
horses so there were some fascinating
detail and to towards the end we heard
from human rights lawyer Adam Wagner who
said that the real danger of these new
police Powers was that it was upsetting
democracy and the idea the notion of
peaceful protest was becoming
radicalized